الصراع ليس وشيكًا أو لا
مفر منه،
الردع قوي اليوم
ومن واجبنا أن نبقيه على هذا النحو،
العالم كله لديه مصلحة
في الحفاظ على السلام والاستقرار في
مضيق تايوان، عالم بأكمله
يعتمد عليه أمن ممرات الشحن التجارية وسلاسل التوريد العالمية.
هذا هو الحال
أيضًا بالنسبة لحرية الملاحة في
جميع أنحاء العالم
ولكن لا يخطئن أحد أن
الصراع
في مضيق تايوان
سيكون مدمرًا
والسؤال بالطبع هو إلى أي مدى
سيكون الصراع مدمرًا في هذه
المنطقة كيف سيبدو نعم
سيبدو سيئًا سيبدو
فظيعًا  لأن تايوان بالطبع
دولة صغيرة جدًا مقارنة بالصين ولكن
الشيء الرئيسي الذي يجب التفكير فيه هو أن
هذا هو مضيق تايوان أه تايوان لديها
جزر هنا وحتى أنها قريبة جدًا من
البر الرئيسي الصيني هنا ولكن ما
هو مهم حقًا هو أن حوالي 60  في المائة من
جميع سفن الحاويات في العالم تمر
بهذا الخط المستقيم أوه واو 60 في المائة
أه خلال الأشهر السبعة الأولى من عام 2022
كان هذا هو الرقم الذي كان يمر عبر هذا الرقم
وهذا الرقم بالتأكيد هو نفسه تقريبًا
هذا العام وربما أكثر من
ذلك ولكن عندما  اذهب إلى بقية
العالم في بحر الصين الجنوبي،
لديك كل نقاط العبور هذه،
ليس فقط مضيق تايوان هنا،
هذه المنطقة المتنازع عليها، ومن
هنا مع بحر الصين الجنوبي،
ولكن أيضًا هذه سنغافورة مضيق
ملقا من خلال هنا
نسبة كبيرة من النفط وجميع
السلع والخدمات، وكل ذلك يمر عبر
كل ما تحتاجه الصين، كل ما تحتاجه
كوريا الجنوبية، كل ما
تحتاجه اليابان وبالطبع ما تحتاجه الكثير من
البلدان الواقعة
شرق هناك الولايات المتحدة
سبيل المثال أيضا بحاجة إلى كل ذلك يأتي
من خلال هذا المجال